I have to ask how much do you enjoy the
constant ribbing that Duane gives you on
social or every day are you like [ __ ]
you Duane well I'm making but it's
coming from a loving place you know our
banter back and forth is it's us being
us I think you know it makes the
friendship friendship where the real
world in it so the the digging the
teaching the fun it's just things that
we literally just grown accustomed to
doing to one another it's always in a
great tone always coming from a place of
love
so I think he's actually probably
winning as it right now I was all run
for a minute where I got him with a
couple good ones but it recently hit
a couple good baby pictures and some
other things that
lasted for a while and with UK meetings
that we use oh he definitely had some
good I really enjoy it from the outside
so I just say I hope you guys keep it up
um I also loved with all my heart seeing
you struggle that bunny on the stage
right it was not a joke so for the
people that don't who are just watching
you didn't see it can you sort of
describe what was supposed to happen and
what actually happened Wow I've worked
with the money before we went out there
so basically it was like Iook heaven
it's easy Bunny's a young bunny very low
movement all I gotta do is make sure
that you cut the bunny and hold the
bunny close to your chest bunny will be
fine
all right tell me that's all I got to do
that's what I'm gonna do sure the money
ain't gonna move bunny not gonna move
when we get out there something happened
this bunny decided to get real active
bunny start crawling up my chest when
people know I don't really deal with
animals like that
get very nervous around him but I didn't
want to make anyone drop the money so it
was a girl thing that make sure I held
the money but also the money starts
scratching so it was almost like a weird
thing that's why I kept I'm almost
called the handler but I knew it was a
bunch of people and I don't want to look
like that much of a wimp so I tried to
handle it as looks that good but I think
I burst it out with this is my nightmare
it's definitely told the truth about how
I felt about the money and about the
craziness that was going on it was it
was awesome to watch because also you
flipped it using like stand-up to just I
mean everyone was laughing moment no it
was great so how excited you for people
to see a secret life of pets - with my
kids my kids are blown away that's the
best critic you know when you have kids
that can literally give you their real
raw opinion based off of a spring that
they just sent with him and watch the
memes use they were laughing non-stop
and I saw though I saw an elevated
version of the movie you know single
life the pets part one was so good so
you know
that's doing part two I was like I hope
that we put ourselves in a position to
to be bigger to be better because you
never wanna go backwards and they did a
great job at it man they did a really
good job with it I love Chris I love
illumination I love my parties in
universe
so I'm glad to be in a great animation
position I know I got a rap with you but
there's real quick I'm so excited to see
the next Jumanji where are you in the
production
how how how would you describe the
script compared to the second it's it's
really good
I'm literally leaving from here going
straight to work after this week now
switch locations going back to Hawaii
you know we're back in the world of
Jumanji but the beautiful thing about
the way we said it is through the video
game atmosphere so in this particular
case we go back in game world
we got back in the game is a way that
who didn't want to thank it again
and the same people are there our same
damn is back together with this
adventure is a it's a much more risky
adventure the states have been elevated
and raised and you know for fan base you
want to give them that same
an invention of the color lovely so we
just want to make sure to be delivered
and Jake Aston I've ever done right here
he does just that
thank you